good afternoon everyone by the way the
I'm going to be using slide Oh for the
questions I'll try and leave some time
at the end for questions but if I do run
out of time I'm gonna try and screenshot
the questions that are posted there and
maybe answer via slack or something like
that so also please feel free to stop me
during the hallway track I'd be happy to
answer questions or if you have any
feedback all right so a quick
introduction about me
so I actually asked my kids to do a
drawing of what I do for a job so this
is what my four-year-old came up with
four year old daughter so apparently
this is her and green and I'm in blue
and she's sitting on my lap or on my
knee while I'm typing at the computer
this is my five-year-old son's
interpretation this is me with my
headphones on typing on my computer I
work from home remotely
I also especially like the binary that's
on the screen although truth be told I
don't actually look at binary on the
computer screen all that often
and finally my six-year-old daughter
she's decided that my job is to sit at
our coffee table and do Legos with she
and her brother and sister well I wish I
sorta wish that was what I did all day
but here's a different take I'm a
principal software engineer at viasat
Inc I'm also a PhD candidate at the
University of Texas Arlington and
there's a chance you may have heard of a
couple other projects I started no VNC
which is a web browser-based VNC client
and the make a lisp project just to note
this this talk is derived from some of
the research that I'm doing for my PhD
and the the challenges and solutions
that I'm going to describe in this talk
apply to a number of different systems
but I'm gonna focus on on browser render
testing as the concrete example so let's
jump in all right so what's the problem
that we're trying to solve well there
are some types of systems that are
really hard to test and they can be hard
to test in a couple of ways I mean
there's lots of different ways that
could be but that
ones that I'm focusing on are the test
cases this challenge is that it can be
hard to find or generate interesting
test cases and by interesting here I
just mean test cases that can actually
trigger bugs and the second major
challenge that I'm focusing on is the
that some systems are hard to verify the
magic box that tells you whether the
system under test is working correctly
is or whether it's not working correctly
is often called the test Oracle and and
so if we want to have a fully automated
testing system both the generation of
the test cases and the test Oracle need
to be fully automated but if the
software to automate automate those
steps ends up being almost as complex as
the system that you're wanting to test
then you have a problem so that brings
us to browser rendering so here's an
example web page this is fairly trivial
but even this page is fairly difficult
to do for a test Oracle to determine
whether this is rendered correctly so
and there's there's a bunch of reasons
for this and I'll touch on a few so one
of them is that the CSS the cascading
stylesheets element sizing and
positioning standard is fairly large and
nuanced it's also one of the basic
things that we want to test in browser
rendering there are environmental
factors like window browser dropped the
geometry of the browser window and what
operating system fonts happen to be
installed the color model the test
Oracle needs to correctly simulate the
color model and things like alpha
blending and font rendering is is a
fairly big problem because subtle
differences in kerning and spacing of
the fonts can shift elements on the page
that's that they they fall off to the
next line and your whole page looks
completely different so a lot of the
solutions current solutions to browser
testing render testing often involved
manual user intervention at some stage
of the process and and a lot of them
also use a fairly constrained test
environment so can we do better can we
do browser testing in a way that's fully
automated without being narrowly
constrained and I think I think we can
so let's talk about that
so the solution that I looked at in the
research that I'm doing is has three
three major components the first is
property based testing the next is
grammar based input generators and the
third is consensus based tests Oracle so
let's consider each one in turn so
property based testing or PBT this is a
testing methodology that was popularized
by the quick check system that was
developed by ken Clawson and John Hughes
in 2000 and in property based testing
the tester defines properties or
assertions about the input and output
values of the system under test the
input properties define the range of
valid inputs to that system under test
and the output properties are used by
the test system to validate outputs for
a given set of inputs or basically
output properties are the test Oracle so
when the output properties are violated
then we know that the corresponding
inputs are considered a failing test
case so a typical PBT system defines
imporant properties in terms of
generator functions generator functions
can be combined to create compound
generators and they can be recursive and
each input property generator function
takes a size value along with a random
seed and that size value has a meaning
that's specific to that generator sort
of a complexity value if you will a
single run of a property base test
involves calling those generator
functions with larger and larger size
values and you do that and that's
basically stochastically generating
random inputs until the output
properties violate and then you know
you've found a failing test case all
right so property based testing is
really effective i compute to be from
personal experience really effective at
finding bugs but the problem is if
you're if your test case is your bug is
buried in a 30 megabyte test case then
it's not really that useful or it's
worse than useful because it's just
noise so and that it the highly
recursive nature of HTML HTML grammar
means that generated test cases can
easily get very large and there is
actually a positive aspect to this which
is that that large test case means that
your hat you have
just in that one test case you have
really broad coverage code coverage
potentially but the major downside of
course is that the those large test
cases aren't useful for root cause
analysis and debugging so in most
property based test systems have a test
shrinking functionality and this this
functionality can significantly reduce
the size of the test case while still
presuming preserving the failure and so
how does that work so we can think of
each test case basically as a tree of
generators generator functions it's
whether the shrinking process does is it
basically picks an arbitrary node in
that tree and it tries it with a smaller
test about smaller size value than it
was originally called with and if the
resulting test case is smaller and it
still fails then the the test that it
continues trying to find smaller test
cases if it passes or yeah if it passes
then it backtracks and this process
continues until some sort of minima is
reached all right so let's let's
consider a simple example of property
based testing so I'm going to define our
import property P as a sequence of
integers and the output property is the
sum of those integers and that sequence
so here's some closure code closure has
a test check library which is an
implementation of property based testing
I needed the the namespace imports but
this is the majority of the tests so
first first what we do is we define the
system under test to be the application
of sum to a sequence and so that's that
and then we define P to be a compound
generator which generates a vector of
integers the output property states that
the execution of the system under test
on P should have the exact same result
as applying a sum to the values in P
then we define our properties using the
props all function implementation detail
there
and finally we call the quick check
function and run 10 - we request it to
run 10 test iterations and finally it
outputs basically results so there were
no failures found in this case which
isn't surprising
and even if we increase the the number
of iterations 200 we see that the result
is unchanging and like I said that's
unsurprising because we've defined our
system under test and our test Oracle
exactly identically so let's change that
a little bit so let's introduce a bug in
our system under test so that if the
system under test is run with a sequence
of integers that's between 13 and 17
long then we'll the result will be a nil
value instead of the sum our properties
remain unchanged we can see that running
tend to test iterations with this with
this new buggy system under test still
passed and the reason is because the
size value it did generate a sequence
that was long enough to trigger the
failure but if we increase our our
number of iterations to 100 we'll see
that on the the 31st iteration the
output property was violated and we
found that failing test case and write
this this is the the sequence of
integers but basically that the value of
the of the test case that caused the
failure then then the the system
continued and it did 262 more iterations
to try and find a smaller test case and
it ended up finding that a sequence of
all zeros of 13 zeros which trigger
trigger the problem so you can see that
that's a lot less and in terms of
complexity in size it's it's smaller all
right so now let's talk about how we how
we do the input properties for the for
browser rendering testing specifically
so in this case we want to generate
webpages which means generating HTML and
CSS and those basically correspond to
the the content and the presentation of
a page respectively and there's a third
component of behavior of a web page it's
typically defined a JavaScript but
that's auto scope for this project all
right so our basic approach is that
first we download and normalize
basically from the web standards we take
the take data from the web event
Anderson normalize that into spec data
then we take that spec data and we we
translate those into ebn F grammars is
sort of a standard language for
context-free grammars then we take that
grammar ebn F and we translate that into
closure generators generator functions
in test check and then we take those
generator functions and the test system
loads those and uses those to generate
our final test cases that it's going to
test with so for a concrete example of
this I'm gonna show just a part of the
CSS standard the cascading stylesheets
standard and the bulk of the standard is
is actually dedicated to defining CSS
values and CSS values are defined using
a bespoke grammar that's called value
definition syntax BDS the grammar is
somewhat similar to EB enough
but it has additional combinators that
are optimized to deal with the ordering
and repetition flexibility that CSS
permits in the values so here's an
example of the VDS definition from from
the CSS spec for the text emphasis
position property listed the values that
are allowed for that and this definition
basically states that the value should
be either the word over and under and
then the word right or left and here's
the basically the equivalent EB and F
grammar that was generated from that
then we take the e BNF grammar and we
translate it into closure test check
generator functions and so here's here's
an example of that the just just a note
here that frequency generator that's a
test check built-in and what that does
is it basically selects between other
generator functions based on weight
values and so you can see that 100 is is
the default value here and so it's gonna
do even 50% chance choice between the
over-under and left-right pairs all
right so one of our goals for the
overall approach is that the system is
controllable and we one of the ways we
accomplish this is we have tunable
weights associated with each branch
point in the grammar and by tuning that
grammar the the tester that's using the
system I can design what we can decide
what sort of testing they want to
perform and some examples of the
different kinds of testing they could
perform by tuning the grammar is single
component testing they could avoid known
failure
they could do pairwise or common
tutorial testing or you know typical and
atypical test cases so here's the
grammar I just showed but this isn't
actually complete yet because it's
emitting the it's emitting the
tunability
so if I add this is the final emitted
grammar what it looks like and you can
see here what's changed is that we're
doing a lookup in the the weights value
here it's a lookup table and it's
basically overlaid the default ways and
it's merged in with the weights from a
configuration file that the tester can
define alright and just this is just an
example what that that file looks like
this is happily closure edn format in
this in this example I've actually
modified the weights to make the over
and write words appear twice as often as
the under and left case okay so now it's
time for a little bit of demo so I'm
gonna Jenny I'm gonna demonstrate what
I've showed so far with basically
property based testing and the grammar
based test case generation so this part
of the project is actually was actually
generically useful and so I split it out
into a different project called instance
to check so let me see if I can get this
to work here all right cool
all right so let's look at a simple EB
enough grammar that we're gonna use to
generate test cases so what this this
grammar does is it basically defines a
file
well a test case that contains whole
numbers that are on lines by themselves
but I won't go into that too much
alright so I'm gonna run my into the
check project I'm going to give it the
grammar and for the first for the first
thing the demo I'm just going to have it
generate generate samples it's not
actually a test anything it's just going
to use the grammar to generate some
examples so if I look at
compare the first and the last examples
that are generated okay so on the left
is the first the first sample I
generated and as it as a generate
samples it's using an increasing size
values and so on the right you can see
that it generated larger larger values
there and more of them so I actually
have a configuration file here it's
already modified so I'm gonna increase
the number seven in this grammar by so
it occurs ten times as often as it would
by default so now I'm gonna run that
same one but I'm gonna specify a grammar
file I'm sorry configuration weights
file look at the samples again and you
can see here that seven because of I
just that that weight now it's happening
almost half half the time so this was an
example of tuning alright so before I
get to the actual testing let me just
show one other thing here and use that
same grammar whoops I want to change my
command sugar and ask for closure code
so this is going to output the closure
equivalent the generators that it's
actually using underneath but it's
outputting the code so this is closure
code if you're familiar with closure
should shouldn't be too hard to read but
basically this is the this is the code
the coolant code that represents that
grammar for generating test cases based
on my grammar alright so go on to the
next part so I have a little more
complicated grammar here this is
basically going to generate simple math
expressions of increasing complexity
and then I also have a test program here
it's just a shell script and in this in
the shell script I define two functions
the system under test and what I've made
this system under test B is basically
just a Python expression evaluator and
then I've defined an Oracle and the
Oracle is basically a ruby version of
the same thing and then at the bottom
here the last line is basically saying
run the system under test with my input
my test case and compare it with the
Oracle to see if there's a tentacle so
now I'm gonna use it in just a check
with that grammar we're gonna give us
the template for how I want to generate
my samples and generate 50 iterations
here or it's going to go 50 iterations
before it stops if it doesn't find
anything and then I tell it what command
I want to run to test with and template
again with the the test the test case
it's gonna fill it in here under the
command so let's run this
alright so it's running the test and
it's going by pretty fast but at some
point it actually ran into a failure and
so it's actually going beyond 50
obviously because it's it hit the
failure and now it's doing the shrinking
process all right so here's the full
result at the end in the middle there is
the the failing test case the expression
that have found that that where the
system under test and the oracle
differed and it hit this problem at test
case 36 and then at the bottom near the
bottom you can see the the smallest
version of the test case that it found
that still trigger the problem so I'm
actually going to use an alternate
version of my test program that just is
more of a boss and run it on the first
failing test case so those are pretty
long numbers and it's a little hard to
see what's going on there I mean if you
look at it for long enough you probably
forget out but let me actually use the
minimal shrunk case that it found so
with this with this run case we can see
that there's
probably a mathematical precision either
on the the calculation of the printing
out and in one or the other or both but
that's an example of how it what the
shrinking looks like alright let's see
so one more thing I just want to show
here so this this is the grammar this is
automatically generated from the
specification data this is the grammar
for HTML and so it's it's really long
and I want to do I'm gonna I'm gonna
just generate samples from this HTML
grammar there are 500 almost 500 rules
grammar rules in this this file so it
takes a few seconds to run to generate
to load that it doesn't take as long if
you actually use the closure code
directly so let's just have a look at
one of these so there's no indenting
here obviously but this is this is one
of the HTML test cases that are
generated alright so let's see if I can
get back to my presentation here all
right so there's another just slide show
another piece of artwork from one of my
kids as my five-year-old son and it's
description of what this project is
about so so I've covered how we generate
test cases using grammars and use
property based testing to run tests
against them so we have we have a way to
do that now that's automated and
controllable but the question is how do
we determine whether a browser has
correctly rendered these test cases in
the automated controllable way so the
key insight here is that the this type
of difficult to test system there's a
subclass of those in which there are
multiple implementations and this is
particularly true in the web browser
space you know we have a few
implementations in fact we really have a
surplus of implementations in the
browser space
so this is an example of another this is
an indented test case that was generated
by the system and here here is
screenshots of that test case rendered
in in three different browsers it's
pretty clear just from visual inspection
that servo servo Bay's by the way is a
new development browser being developed
by Mozilla and it's pretty clear from
this that the server browser is
different than the others it's not
immediately clear though whether Chrome
and Firefox are different and so let's
move these around and then insert
different images so what this is doing
is subtracting the color channels for
each pair of browser screenshots and so
the black areas represent where there
was no difference and any other colors
represents some sort of difference
between those pair of browsers so now
it's pretty easy to see that the servo
Firefox and servo chrome difference
there's pretty significant difference
there but we can also see it's a bit
it's a bit clearer now also that there
is some subtle differences between
Firefox and Chrome but this actually
raises the question our firefox and
chrome actually different is that a
failure and so you know now we now we
ask the question do we have consensus
and they're actually numerous ways of
comparing images in the research
literature there's even some literature
you know discussing how to use machine
learning approaches to be able to
determine if two browsers rendered a
page in a way that's indistinguishable
to human eye but the the fact actually
is that a tester is probably going to
want to control this they're gonna want
it there weren't depending what they're
trying to accomplish they're going on to
determine how browsers renderings are
compared and so for this research we
found that just using a squared sum of
differences of the difference image to
get a single value and then comparing it
to a threshold value was sufficient to
validates approach okay so now we have
an answer for whether each pair of
browsers are different from each other
with with three browsers there are
obviously three different Delta
images and and so the question now
becomes what if they disagree and
there's there's there's some different
categories of disagreement you could
have what I just showed well kind of
where one browse you know to browse
basically are in agreement with each
other and there's a single browser in
the case of three but basically you can
have a single browser that's different
from all the others and all the others
are self similar to each other so in
that case you know it's not that this
isn't a proof that that browser is doing
it incorrectly but especially in the
browser case you know we're often more
interested in is it the same as other
browsers rather than is it like
mathematically correct according to the
standards so so if there's one browser
that's different it's pretty clear that
it is fault but there's some other cases
we could have a case where all the
browser's are different from each other
that's pretty common actually and where
this happens is where you have web
specifications or lack of a web
specification for certain elements on
the page or the specification is big
it's one of the one of the common cases
where we found out I know there's
there's some interesting cases where no
browser is at fault actually and well or
there's no obvious browser at fault so
one example of this is where we could
have browser a and browser B their
difference is below the threshold brows
would be and browser C their differences
below the threshold but then when you
consider the difference between a and C
the difference is now above the
threshold and what's happened is
basically B is sort of split the
difference between the two different
renderings and so you know what what
does that mean in that case and and
really the answer is that it depends on
what you're trying to test and so you
really want the the tester what really
wants to have control over over over the
meaning of the consensus all right so
just real quickly and you're going to go
over the the architecture of our our
testing system so on the left is about
this where the Mozilla developer Network
actually has some of the best sources
for a specification data in more
programmatic form and so we take that
data and we run it through an automated
process that basically generates our
grammars
and our generators and we store them
basically - in our data store and then
on the right we have at the top right is
basically our browser consensus pool and
our our system has an embedded web
server so that the browser's can load
those test cases from the data store and
then the the green box inside the larger
one on the right is basically our test
driver and what that does is that
connects via the webdriver
the selenium webdriver protocol to our
our consensus pool tells the browsers to
load the current test case being
considered once that test case is loaded
then it screenshots screenshots all the
browser's stores that to the data store
generates the Delta images and and does
the comparison for for consensus or not
and and stores all that logs all that
data including the difference the delta
images to the data store for review
later all right so let's do our next
demo
okay so I call this part of this project
tend there's not really a good reason
for that name historical reasons I may
change it at some point but this is what
I'm trying here is just a configuration
file for our testing system there's a
you know different different categories
of configuring the system so we're this
is the the quick check or the property
based testing configuration then we can
specify a weights file for configuring
the weights that we want to use here's
our comparison configuration for
comparing images with our threshold
value for after you get the squared sum
of differences that we compare it to
this threshold value to determine
whether those browsers are different
enough from each other the embedded web
server and data store configuration and
then the configuration for the browser
consensus pool and by the way this the
the project does support pointing out
browser stack so you can use you know
different versions of you know arbitrary
browsers that that browser stack sports
without having to run the the test
harness or the test drivers for your
browser locally if you want okay so I am
going to start a test run
okay so this is gonna start up it's
going to start the embedded web server
it's going to load load connect to the
the browsers and the consensus pool and
then it's going to start generating our
test cases so you can see that this you
know we're already up to the fifth test
case here and we've already found we
already found a violation there where
there's a disagreement all right so let
me see if this will work okay so here's
here's a report page so the the embedded
web server also has a reporting
mechanism so I can tell it can show you
status of the current test run and so
this also has a establishes a WebSocket
connection to the to the server and gets
dynamic dynamically gets the test
information as it's being updated and
and updates that on the page so on this
page the the what the columns are
showing here okay there we go all right
so the different columns here so on the
left is the the current test iteration
number the the green and red colors
represent whether the test cases are
passing or failing and we can see here
that on the fifth the fifth iteration it
hit hit a failing test case where the
the differences were were greater than
the threshold value we set and then
there's also yeah so there the the first
few columns are the screenshots of the
browsers and the consensus pool there's
an average column and then the rest of
the columns are the difference the delta
images in this case there's just one
delta image because we know this is only
showing two browsers all right
the tests actually finished completed
and in the on the top there's a summary
line that shows one of the most
interesting parts is that it shows the
initial test failure the number of bytes
and shows the shrunk number of bytes
that it was able to reduce the failing
test case to okay
all right oh okay good hello no no don't
do that no that's me okay maybe didn't
do this before alright well we'll try
and keep going even if it's switching
just a time
alright so finally I couldn't resist
throwing it one more this is my
six-year-old daughter asked to describe
what this is about and I think it's
about as accurate than anything else so
okay so let me just let me just review
real quick
so the challenges of browser render
testing that I've addressed basically
fall into sort of two categories the
automatic test case generation and the
test oracle and you can kind of sum it
up as end-to-end test integration or a
test automation and there are three
basic components to the solution that
I'm proposing which the first is
property based testing and critically
important there is test drinking grammar
based input generators and there's the
the standalone project that can do
property based testing of grammars
grammar defined inputs called insta-tuck
and then the consensus based Oracle to
be able to automate the determining
whether the case is correct okay and
that's all I have
just a few links where you can go for
further information so this presentation
itself is at that first link and then
the projects are the next links my
twitter handle email and also I'll throw
in a plug here I work like I mentioned
it bias at and it's a it's a great
company to work for we're doing really
interesting stuff and also we have
satellites in space so you know there's
that but if you're interested at all
check out the careers page and and
finally just I want to call it thanks to
my the chair of my dissertation with
Vinnie David Levine at UTA so I think I
think we have a few minutes for
questions here
let me pull up the slide Oh page see
little update
maybe all right okay so do you see
applications of this work to testing
websites themselves in addition to
browser rendering engines it's a good
question yeah I think it could
definitely be used for that there yeah I
think it wouldn't it wouldn't be that
hard that basically swap out the grammar
the grammar generator and just have you
know a corpus of the webpages or the or
have some something serving up the web
page one note that is that this is
fairly static web page so it's it's
going to be more useful for testing the
rendering so there need to be if you
wanted to test you know behaviors there
be there be more work that you'd have to
do for sure but it should be pretty easy
to plug in if you want to test web pages
rather than browsers for sure all right
another question here do you have any
tricks to simplify the generation of
tests involving dependencies between CSS
properties eg z-index requiring a non
static position right okay so what this
question basically gets to the bottom of
is that the the grammar language that
I'm using is is context-free grammar so
there isn't there isn't a way to have it
it referenced some other thing that
you've already generated so I think the
system the architecture of the system
itself is pretty generic so you could
plug in a different grammar language and
then translate from that to the
generators because the generators the
the closure generators could easily
support context but but the grammar Eby
enough grammar itself is context-free
and so you can't have you know generate
something and then generate something
based off of that so so the answer is
the current system no you can't do that
but but I think I think would be pretty
easy to just swap in a different grammar
language to generate not easy but it's
definitely possible all right
so do any of these test failures
translate into high-priority bugs or is
it mostly finding edge cases that's
that's a good question
the this is actually an area of ongoing
research that's that's in a sense the
next area that I'm really going to do is
try and to try and run this and tune the
system to be able to really find bugs I
have actually found the reason why it's
only showing in this demo only showing
Firefox in chrome is because I did in
running the system did discover a bug in
servo where it crashes after the 12th
12th screen shot and so and this only
happens in in headless mode with I think
just with the webdriver protocol active
so so that is a real bug and it did if
the system did find that it wasn't the
type of bug I was looking for obviously
but you know it did it did find a real
bug and you know there it's I suppose
you know it is a question is is
disagreement between say the applet HTML
element which was you know an obsolete
element that you probably won't find you
know that is all browser basically
disagree on how to render that even when
it's there's no applet being run and so
you know I guess in one way that's a
false positive but you know it really is
it really did find a difference and it
does quickly find differences between
browsers and they are really legitimate
differences so let's see does anybody in
the room have questions that they
weren't able to ask using the slide Oh
app yeah yeah yeah so the question is
how much time to have to spend on
testing the Oracle well I think that
would be more applicable if the Oracle
was actually doing some sort of logic
about the page I mean it's it's more
relevant when your Oracle actually has
logic that's trying to trying to verify
the the system under test in this case
there was a lot of a lot of work I had
to do to get to normalize the screen
captures and get it so they're actually
comparable of comparable size and so
there's a lot of work there but it
wasn't so much in it wasn't so much in
the oracle algorithm itself the workflow
algorithm is pretty straightforward
right it's just you know screenshotting
the images getting the deltas between
all the the screenshots and then you
know doing a squirts on a difference in
comparing comparing where there's a
difference so I use open CV for a lot of
the image processing stuff and you know
figuring it out it took time but it
didn't have to spend that much time to
bugging it once it got it working
so yeah
yeah
so the way I got around that is that I
didn't develop the grammar myself I mean
there's a few headers to the grammar
that you know I put in myself to load
like some standard normalizing CSS that
a lot of pages use because browsers for
example have differences and what the
margin and padding defaults for the body
is and so I need to normalize that so
so that's hard-coded in the grammar but
the rest of the grammar is actually
generated programmatically from
specification data and that's actually a
good point I did find some bugs in the
specification data itself that not not
the web standards but they were the way
they were imported to the Mozilla
developer Network had some had some
errors but but yeah I mean that's a
that's a good point that you know if if
your inputs are really complicated and
creating the grammar for it
you know if there's if it doesn't exist
or if for example it's not context-free
then there's you know there's work there
to be done obviously so yeah
so the question is being able to look at
an existing web page and generate the
code for it yeah so actually that's a
really good question the next the next
step in the research is actually to be
able to look at a corpus of web pages
which may be just one and use the
grammar because we have a grammar for a
web page now and I actually have some
patches to the insta parse library which
was the library underneath I use for the
grammars and what it does is actually
logs the path through the grammar and
and generates a weight's file based on
that that page or that set of pages and
so then you can take that weights file
turnaround use the system and it will
generate cell you know pages that have
similar types of elements on the page so
and I've I've done that some it's still
you know I'm 75% of the way done figures
with that bit yeah it's a good question
that's the next next thing we're working
on okay yeah that's just one last
question
yeah good question so the question is
about if you have a recursive recursive
generator you know what how do you avoid
base B falling into the case where you
don't have you know it just keeps going
forever and you get it you know six
gigabyte test case and and the answer is
I cheated and use the test check
actually has a lot of a lot of the price
should say a lot of the property based
test systems have have a way of
generating recursive grammars so they
actually have a generator that says
here's here's the outside here's the
inside part and actually it prevents you
from from going infinite so you use this
it uses the size value to actually
determine how far it how far it recursos
so all right I think I'm out of time so
like I said if you have any questions
more questions please feel free to stop
me I'll be down here for a few minutes
although I think that probably the next
presentation is up so
[Applause]